these volunteers are preparing for Vital
work that they know is needed now
some are veterans or work in the
emergency services others have office
jobs but they all have a unique skill
set and a desire to help people it's why
15 of them are heading to Southeastern
turkey what do we do with all those
displaced people who've lost their homes
lost everything they're going to need
shelter they're going to need food
supply they're going to need fresh
portable drinkable water and they're
going to need access to medical
facilities so we can help facilitate all
of that for them as a former Army medic
and now nurse Sarah feels compelled to
go with this disaster there's
Devastation not just structurally but
family units have been absolutely torn
apart I've got family of my own we're
very lucky that you know the the well
looked after I've got loads of family
support I just want to go out and help
people and bolster the UK's effort
tons of desperately needed medical
supplies have also been loaded at Raf
Bryce Norton we're traveling with a
group of Highly specialized clinicians
ranging from Obstetricians to General
Practitioners nurses doctors of
different Specialties we're currently
traveling with our type 1 facility to be
able to support delivering Primary
Health Care where it's needed most don't
just think turkey this is affected over
into that Syrian side as well
and it may be at some point the
conditions are set to enable us to go
across there for now they are all
providing a Lifeline to Turkey but this
tea aren't ruling out Crossing into
Syria I mean we've got to be pragmatic
about this there are thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people who need
help and we've got to look at where we
can get too quickly and then have an
immediate effect
Sarah is much more challenging there are
lots of people who need help there we
will start to reflect now on whether we
can shift our attention in that
direction but not until we've got this
line going and we know we're helping
people in need when disasters hit it
takes bravery Beyond Comprehension to
run towards the danger but they know
their presence could be invaluable
in Salisbury